According to UNO in India alone every
day more than 7,000 females
after they have come to know they
aborted abortion takes place before they
are born killed
or after they are born they are killed.
According to a government hospital
report in Tamil Nadu out of 10 female
born alive four are put to death. How
many four?
So in India every day 10 years ago
previously a BBC report in '90s had said
1 million a year. If you multiply 7 it
was 3,000 a day.
If you multiply 3,000 by 365 comes to
more than a million a year. If you
multiply 7,000 a day multiply by 365
comes to more than 2.5 million.
So in 2015,
10 years ago, more than 2.5 million
females are being killed every year
before they are born or immediately
after they are born. 2.5 million a year.
More the science is advancing, you have
more females being killed.
And even in China, same thing. So these
two countries India has 17.75
percentage of the world population.
Today India has 1.42 billion out of 8
billion comes to 17.75. China is little
less 17 and a half%. Both put together
more than 35%.
More than 35% of the world population is
India and China. And both these
countries there are female feticides,
female infanticide.
If you stop this evil practice in a few
decades now India and China are one of
the few countries in the world where the
female population is less. That's the
reason there is a imbalance.
If this evil practice stops even in
these two countries and all other
countries the female population will
become more than the mole population
because scientifically and medically a
female sex is the stronger sex
medically. They can survive better. They
die less in wars, less in diseases. And
they have a larger lifespan.
On average, on average, the world
average that a man lives is 70.7 years.
World average. Man, woman put together
73.3%.
Only women 76 years. Sorry. 70.3 years.
73 73.3 years. That means 73 years and 4
months. The average of human beings that
live in the world is 73 years and 4
months. But the average man that lives
in the full world is 70.7 years and a
woman is 76 years.
That means a woman lives 5.3 years more
than a man average.
And every country differs the best
average is of Hong Kong. It's according
to World Ometers. You Google get the
reply all what they can you can verify
just ask shake Google or ask AI
artificial intelligence chat GDP ask
them the question that's depending upon
the society depending upon the climate
depending upon the culture depending on
what you eat the average keeps on
changing the best average in the world
is Hong Kong
85.6 years
85.6 6 years average man women put
together and the least is Nigeria
54.6 6 years. That means a person in
Hong Kong on an average man or woman
lives 31 years more than a man in
Nigeria
average.
But generally a woman lives 5.3
years more than a man.
So today if you check the statistics
of the CIA world fact book again in 2016
in 2015
it says that New York that New York
alone has half a million female more
than male. USA alone has 4.8 million
females more than male.
In Germany alone 1.2 million females are
more than male.
In Bangladesh alone, 4.2 million females
are more than males.
In Russia alone, 10 million females are
more than male. In European Union, 28
countries put together 10.2 million
females are more than male. And God
knows Allah knows how many females are
more than males throughout the world.
It is only because of India and China
that now if you see overall average is
same over or average of man and woman is
the same. Why? Because there's evil
happening in India and China.
Every year 2.5 million females are put
to death before they are born after they
are born immediately. 2.5 million a
year.
China also would be similar. That is the
reason now if you check what is the
average of man and woman approximately
equal because if this evil practice
stops again women will be more in India
and China. So I'm asking you the
question in a society where women are
not being killed like India or